thank you so much
go ahead awesome okay well so uh good
morning slash good afternoon slash good
evening
uh everyone um this is i believe unless
we
schedule something random this is the
last of the officially scheduled physics
track
lectures for week zero which is um i'm
sure
exciting saddening for everyone uh
depending on how you've found them so
far
um and so this is intended to be a kind
of a very brief introduction to this
framework that we've developed
called called multi-way system or now i
suppose global multi-way system to
distinguish it from the
local multi-wave system that's
implemented in multiple model which is a
a it's a general tool i essentially
designed for dealing with abstract
rewriting systems
of any kind be they will from model
systems substitution systems cellular
automata
turing machines you know any any other
kind of system where there isn't a sort
of canonical deterministic updating
order defined
um and so it's a i hope a fairly general
fairly abstract fairly extensible
framework
uh that that again i hope will be useful
to many of you in the projects that
you're going to be doing over the next
few weeks
and so i kind of want to give you a
brief introduction to to the multi-wave
system framework
and several of several other functions
that i've developed or that we've
developed
that kind of go around it and plug into
it in various ways
um okay so let me let me just begin by
the way i should apologize to begin with
if if my sound quality is a bit weird i
was just telling aaron um it's an
uncharacteristically warm day in the uk
at the moment so uh unlike normal i have
a desk fan
currently pointed directly at my face
which you might be able to hear i don't
know
um but apologies if you can uh okay
so hopefully you guys can see my screen
and hopefully you will complain at me if
you can't and i didn't
share the wrong thing like i did
yesterday um okay
so let's deal with the sort of simplest
case of this so if we call resource
function
you know as with all of our functions
they're all in the function repository
you can call them
uh just you don't need to download
anything you can call everything just
using the function repository resource
system
so if we input able from model rule like
an x y x
z goes to x y x w
y w z w uh and we give it initial
condition so we'll give it two
uh self loop uh we'll give it two uh two
self loop nodes
as the initial condition and let's say
run this for three steps
so obviously if we just plug this into
wolfer model without running some sort
of a local multi-way system or something
this would this would choose some
default updating order but if we plug
this into a multi-way system
we will get uh all possible updating
orders so uh in fact i'm gonna
i'm gonna do a bit of rescaling on the
graph give it give each vertex a
reasonable size so you can actually see
what's going on
and i'm going to declare an aspect ratio
of one half that will make
for some reason when you have layered
digraphs in the wolfram language
sometimes they lay out in a very kind of
squashed format which isn't very useful
anyway so this is what we see so we
started off from this two self-loop
initial condition here
and then after one step there was from
the two self loop initial condition
there was only one update that could get
applied but then there were three
possible updates that
could have got applied and so we could
obtain these three different hypergraphs
and from there there were a whole bunch
and you'll see that as well as
bifurcations there are also mergings so
this is another sort of key difference
between the multi-way system framework
and the wolfram model framework and the
local multi-way system framework which
is that this global multi-way system
framework has
state equivalences so in the wolfram
model case that means it has the ability
to determine hypograph isomorphism
and to use that as the merging criteria
for states in the multi-wave system
so the way that works is using some
isomorphism functions i developed so if
we call
isomorphic hypergraph q it takes
essentially the same uh syntax as
uh isomorphic graphq that's built into
the wolfram language so if we give it a
hyper graph that contains a mixture of
rt3 edges and rt2 edges like
cb uh ba and we
and then we can ask is that is this
hypograph isomorphic sorry that's
one too many uh braces there we can ask
is this hypograph isomorphic to two four
four five
one uh one three three two and if you
stare at that for a moment you'll
realize that these are in fact the same
just you know a
replaced with four and e replaced with
five and d replaced with one and so on
uh so if we call this uh then it in fact
determines that
that those hypergraphs were indeed
isomorphic and if we really wanted to we
could find the actual hypograph
isomorphism
uh this is not as uh the output for this
is not
still not perfect i keep meaning to go
back and make this a little bit more
helpful but i
somehow never have time but um so so
it's indicating you know
for each vertex in the left hypograph
what are the vertices in the right
hypergraph that that vertex could be
mapped to
under some uh under some bijection um
so so these are this is effectively an
association that parameterizes the
possible isomorphisms that exist between
these two hypographs
it's worth noting of course that in this
in the default case unless we unless you
explicitly override it using the
multi-way system options
all hypergraphs or all will from model
hypographs and global multi-way systems
are treated as ordered hypographs in
which the ordering of the of the
elements in each relation actually
matters
and so in reality what we're using is
the merging criterion is not isomorphic
hypograph q
but actually isomorphic ordered
hypograph q
uh which works like that and so you know
if we did something like we changed the
we swapped the d and the e around here
of course in the unordered hypergraph
case those are still isomorphic but in
the ordered hypograph case they're not
and so so in that case if these two
hypergraphs appeared at some level in
the multi-way system they would not be
merged unless we explicitly told
multi-wave system that we were dealing
with or
with uh order of the typographs
okay so uh but as i say multi-way system
uh doesn't just
the global multi-way system framework
doesn't just work with waffle models it
works with any kind of abstract
rewriting system
so if i give an example of say a string
substitution system so
string substitution systems are nice
because they're they're reasonably
minimal they show
kind of all of the interesting
properties that you would expect to see
in a multi-way system but they're very
efficient
to run because hypergraph isomorphism as
you would expect is a very hard
algorithmic problem but string
equivalence is a trivial algorithmic
problem
and so because the you know the main uh
the main bottlenecking global multi-way
system is in fact the equivalence
testing it's the isomorphism testing
it means that string multi-way systems
run significantly faster than more from
model ones so for a lot of the things
i'm going to demonstrate here i'm going
to use strings
as a sort of canonical the canonical
example so if i give it a list of string
substitutions
a goes to baa baa goes to a b and an
initial condition aaa
uh here so this is effectively running
uh
what this is basically giving you is the
same result you would have got from a
function like string replace list
so it's telling you from the initial
condition aaa there are two
by just applying these rules there are
two possible strings we could get a b a
b
a a then from those two strings there
are five possible strings we could get
and from there uh seven and so on um and
so if we wanted to
if rather than just seeing lists of
those things uh if we wanted to we could
see
the states graph to see how each of
those strings leads to each of the other
strings
and so you can see this is nicely laid
out in the kind of with each generation
shown
as a separate layer although that that
won't be true in general uh
for a states graph it will be true in
general for what we call an evolution
graph
and i would like to explain the
difference between those two cases in in
a moment
um and so as well as giving it lists of
updating rules we can also give it lists
of initial conditions so i don't know if
i do baa
there then we get a different uh
different evolution
and you can see both aaa as that initial
condition and where
wherever baa is oh it ended up being a
completely separate multi-way system
because those two states
there were no states in this one that
ever merged with that one but maybe that
would change if we ran it a bit longer
or maybe not i have no idea what i'm
doing okay yeah there we go so
aba there ends up being a normal form
and so those two
multi-way systems eventually merged okay
so in addition to just showing the
states graph uh which is only showing
that
the particular expressions that are
obtained we could also
show things like events so uh by default
you'll notice if
we just called uh if we called
multi-system without any properties
specified
um then it would it would show four
evolution it would evolve the multiwave
system for four evolution steps and then
show the states list so that would be
the same
as if we requested the property all
states list uh but we could also show
something like all events list
and we can see each where each event
actually got applied so
uh so the way you you can read out this
event specification and we'll talk a lot
more about event specifications later
but the way that these events are
specified in multi-way system is is
again using kind of
the most general format that we could we
could come up with which is
on the left it's the particular rule
that got applied so in this case it's a
a goes to baa
then the the second element of the list
is uh what the what the input for the
rule was which in this case is a a
which is pretty obvious it's the left
hand side of the rule but for something
like a wolfram model rule
where instead of it being a literal rule
like for a string it's actually a
pattern rule
uh then then the then the the rule that
got applied and
the input for that rule will actually be
different one of them will be a pattern
one of them will be a literal so
although in string in string systems
this is kind of giving you redundant
information for something like a wolf
model system it's not redundant
um and then the the third element of the
list is itself a list that contains the
prefix
and the suffix so in this case it's
telling you the prefix was was null
and the suffix was a so this is a way of
saying what we've done is we've taken
the the initial
uh state which was uh i think aaa and
then we've so
so to the first aaa here we've applied
this rule and then so then there was no
prefix but there is a suffix of a
um and again this is this is sort of the
general format that we use for all of
our multi-way systems so if we took like
this multi-way system
for the wolfer model case and we
requested it to all events list
again it's going to take a moment but
but it's specified in exactly the same
way okay
the rules happen to be rule delays
rather than immediate rules but other
than that
they're essentially the same it's just
that the rules operate on hypergraphs
rather than
operating on strings okay so
as well as actually displaying the
events as just sort of
in their raw list format we could also
show them as as graphics so we could say
evolution events graph
so that would show us essentially the
state it's the same as the states graph
that we saw before
but now in addition to just the states
we're also showing these yellow boxes
which are the events
and so for the strings you know these
events are quite easy to understand
you can see uh if we take this event
here
what it's saying is that the prefix was
a b that there's no suffix
and we applied the we applied the rule
that a goes to baa and if we did
we did a similar evolution events graph
but for the wolfram model case we'd see
a similar
specification of those events so if we
did something like this
and we did evolution events graph
uh maybe three evolution steps was a bit
ambitious this
takes these take not only do they take a
while to compute they also take a while
to render
um
i might kill this in a minute if it
doesn't render soon oh no
okay rendered there we go
okay and so now you can see as well as
as well as all the states in that
multi-way evolution
you can also see each of each individual
event uh so you can see so so
from the from the dashed lines and from
the red lines this is uh max's
this is the event rendering code for
from max's set replace
um framework uh for so from the dash
lines and from the red lines you can see
which hyper edges have been created
which hyperedges are about to be
destroyed
um okay so then if we
uh go a step further we could also
request not just information about the
evolution but we can also request
information about the causal
relationships and again i'm going to
i'm going to do this for strings first
because it'll be simpler and
faster so if we call something like
evolution causal graph
now what that's going to show is not
just the states and the events and the
evolution edges which are still gray
but it's also going to show the causal
edges so now what this is say okay let
me let me do a simpler case of this and
let me get rid of that redundant
thing there okay that's maybe a little
bit easier to understand
so uh so now this is so starting from
our initial state here
we could apply these two events and we
can get these two states
and then we're saying for for the which
of the future events have causal
dependencies
on the on these previous events and so
those those things are shown in orange
um so here you can see that there are um
we have causal relationships between
events on single branches of history but
if we start running the evolution graph
if we start running the multi-wave
system for a longer period of time and
you start getting mergers
you'll see that they're start appearing
causal edges that actually link
different uh
different evolution branches and so
those are those are effectively
the the fact that you can have causal
relationships not just on single
branches of history but between branches
of history
is how we obtain effective quantum
mechanical behavior in in global
multi-wave systems and i'm going to
explain
a bit about how that works later on um
if you don't want to have all the
information about the evolution
if you don't if you don't care about the
individual states that you reach you
just want to know about the causal
relationships between the elements
then you can just call causal graph and
you'll get the full multi-way causal
graph
that parameterizes that evolution and
obviously from the multi-from the
multi-way causal graph it's always
possible for you to reconstruct the
evolution causal graph
because just knowing this event you
immediately know what its predecessor
state and what its successor state
states were because you you know you can
infer that from the input the output
the prefix and the suffix of the event
itself
so essentially all of the information
you could ever care about
with respect to the multi-way system is
encoded in the multi-way causal graph
and all of the other stuff is kind of
just
is uh is syntactic sugar in some sense
okay uh but as i mentioned uh you know
multi-way system is a
framework that i tried to design to be
as general as possible so
uh we although we've mostly looked at um
string substitution systems and will
model systems
we could also use it on something like a
list system so if i do
0 goes to 0 1 0 0 0 goes to 1
um oops sorry
and i started out from the initial list
0 1 0 and i run it for three steps and i
call and
i request an evolution causal graph uh
then we get this thing here
which is i mean so this is now a list
substitution system as opposed to a
string substitution system but in all
other respects you know the state
rendering the event rendering is the
same and in fact we get the same result
here as if we replaced all the zeros
with a's and all the ones with b's uh we
can show that
you know it's kind of trivial to
simulate list substitution systems using
string substitution systems
we did something like this we get the
same evolution causal graph just with
different uh different event and state
rendering
uh we could also we could also use
something like a cellular automaton
so in an ordinary cellular automaton
because you're updating everything from
from left to right and you know in
blocks of three cells at a time there's
always one updating order but in a sense
you can think of
each application of the cellular
automaton rule as being a separate
rewrite event that's taking a block of
three cells
and replacing it with a block of three
cells where the where the center cell is
replaced
with or where the sensor cell can be
different and the left and right cells
are
made the same so given a cellular
automaton rule you can basically convert
it into a list of
into a list of list substitution rules
which replace triples of elements with
other triples of elements
and so you can construct a mul and by by
applying
either periodic or transmissive boundary
conditions you can construct a multi-way
extension
of a cellular automaton so if we take
something like steven's favorite
rule 30 and we started out with initial
condition i know 0
0 1 0 0. we do something like that
again this takes a little time because
of the event rendering and state
rendering but hang on if i do vertex
size goes to 1
then we see this immensely complicated
uh evolution
evolution causal graph for rule 30 let
me actually not do it for three steps
let's only do it for two steps that
might be a bit easier to see
so you can see that we we started from
from this state here the zero zero one
zero zero state and then these are all
the events we could apply
these are the other states we can reach
these are the causal relationships
between those events
and then that means unlike in a regular
cellular automaton in addition to doing
uh just having a single cellular
automaton rule we could also have
sets of subs of cellular automaton rules
and apply them both simultaneously or
apply the whole set simultaneously
so if we say 170 which i think is the
left shift
cellular automaton so it takes the
center cell and shifts it to the to the
left
and 240 which is the right shift center
of automaton and we apply them both
then we get uh then we get this thing
here which is
because left shifts and and right you
know because left shifts and right
shifts don't sort of conflict with each
other
we know that the cellular automaton is
trivially causing an invariant and i
mean if you want to
i'm i'm going to cover cause and
variance related functions uh in a
little while but if you want to skip
ahead a little bit
we can indeed verify that that's true um
okay uh so other things you could do i
mean so in addition to cellular automata
or lists you could also run it with kind
of built in with a model substitution
system so if we write uh
we write out our list substitution
system explicitly as a warfare model uh
sorry as a wall from language
substitution system then using the
built-in substitution system function
then we can do that as well so if i do
something like this
oh sorry that was incorrect
i did something wrong
ah okay if i do that yeah okay there we
go so there we there we're simulating
this stuff this this wolfram language
substitution system uh but as a
multi-way evolution
uh okay um
so there so there are a bunch of these
systems that are built into into a multi
into the multi-way system framework
itself
there are also a bunch of kind of add-on
functions that i've developed that use
the core multi-way system framework and
that allow you to simulate an even more
diverse range of systems
that are a bit more specialized so one
example is is combinator evaluations so
in combinatory logic
uh the value again the evaluation order
you can define an evaluation semantics
but the evaluation order isn't sort of
defined a priori
so if we define say sean finkel's s and
k combinatory calculus so if we say
s of x y z see if i can remember how
this works so
x of z y of z and then
k of x y oh we should use rule delayed
rather than rule
so here so then we do that goes to just
x and then let's try s of k of s of i
of s of k
k of i something like that
wait have i not
yeah let's try that that should do
something maybe
we'll see oops what did i do
i had too many brackets this is what i
get for trying to do
uh experiments on the fly okay what did
i do wrong
uh there's this graph
oh yeah i missed its graph thank you yes
perfect
sorry who was that i'm
it oh it was me oh good spot william
sorry yeah nice one uh this was not as
interesting a multi-way system as i was
expecting to produce but anyway okay
you see you see what happened so we
started off from some expression in
combinatory logic
there were two possible initial
applications of these of the s and k
combinatory calculus
uh but then eventually because lambda
calculus satisfies the church roster
property eventually we ended up with a
single uh evolution branch
uh okay but we could also um some of you
will have seen stephen's recent uh blog
uh sort of bulletin on on rulialspace
which used this function i developed
called multi-way turing machine
which takes in a specification of
touring of a collect so an ordinary
turing machine in the wolfram language
is a deterministic turing machine
where you just specify a single turing
machine rule and it applies it
you know there's only one place where
the event can get applied at each step
but if you have multiple touring machine
rules that could be different events
that could be applied
you know a given given a particular
state of the machine and the state of
the tape
and so to to so effectively what you get
is a non-deterministic turing machine
uh and so i wrote the function multi-way
turing machine to kind of deal with that
that multi-way case
so if we give it a specification of two
two two turing machine rules so two
states two color turing machines
uh with with indices two five oh six and
three five o six
then we can give it uh an initial state
uh an initial tape
which let's give it a five simple tape
and let's again call state's graph
and we'll end up okay we'll get
something that's again very small so we
can't see what's going on
let's try that okay so then you can see
these are the possible evolution
histories for that non-deterministic
turing machine let's run a little bit
longer
and let's look at i don't know it's
evolution causal graph because that
might be kind of interesting
so then you can see again not only the
evolution of this non-deterministic
turing machine
but actually the the sets of causal
relations between uh between the
updating events in that turing machine
um okay again something else that is
still kind of under development and and
is still kind of a
kind of pretty hacky but that i'm kind
of uh
we're interested in getting a more
complete version of this working and
integrated with the
quantum computing framework that i
developed but a very very early version
of our sort of multi of our quantum
circuit to multi-way system compiler
is also available from the function
repository although it does a bunch of
really hacky things that i hope to
repair soon
but if we do something like we specify
hadamard gate so one one one
one minus one and we give it an initial
state so one minus one
and we request its evolution graph then
we can see the evolution of that
of that quantum uh circuit so we're just
starting from
an initial state vector one minus one
and we're seeing what happens if we
apply this hadamard gate to that system
uh three times and so if we if we wanted
to we could say uh include
state pathways and again don't worry i'm
gonna walk you through what these
options mean and how
what you know what we're actually doing
later on but if i then say vertex weight
okay so then at the end you can see so
so what includes state pathways
is doing is it's saying uh you know what
how many possible paths
led to that particular state so so we're
sort of we're weighting each node by the
number of evolution part
number of distinct evolution paths that
led into that state uh so you can see
there were four evolution paths that
into minus one zero
two that led into zero minus one and so
on so if we did four times you know
minus one zero
plus two times 0 minus 1
plus 6 times 0 1 plus 4 times 1
0. we'd get 0 4 which is the same as
which is the same result that we would
get if we took matrix power of the
hadamard gate 1
minus one and just applied it to the
initial state one minus one uh we if we
did that
sorry if we applied that multiplicity
three we'd get the same result
okay anyway i might talk a bit more
about that later um again i
i unfortunately couldn't make it to the
uh to the livestream bulletin writing
session that you guys did yesterday i'm
not entirely sure what you guys
worked on but i understand you were
working on these these multi-way
function systems which take kind of
multi-way systems where the individual
elements are integers and where the
replacement rules are functions on
integers
so to accommodate that uh i developed
this function called multi-function
system
which so takes if you take if you give
it something like two
let's give it a pure function which so
given an integer it outputs two possible
integers so let's say take the integer
add one
uh take the integer multiply by two add
one take the integer multiply by three
subtract one
then we can write that out as a pure
function uh
and then uh let's start with initial
integer four
let's start with initial integer one and
run it for four steps and let's get a
states graph
and we get this and then uh i mean i i
again i'm not sure whether you guys
actually
covered this in the in the sort of um
live stream with steven yesterday but
then you can also do things like
evolution causal graphs
these get a little bit funky because the
uh unlike for something like a string or
a wolfram model or any of these other
systems we've investigated
for something like an integer it's not
immediately clear what the what the
individual elements are
and therefore you know to determine
causal relationships you have to be able
to determine you know which events
created certain elements which events
destroyed certain elements so for so and
with integers it's not immediately clear
how you go about doing that
um for in this particular implementation
i decided to use the
you know use the basic property that all
integers have a unique factorization
and so then use the actual prime
factorization of the integer to give you
the sets of elements so then what your
what the causal relationships are
showing you is which events produced
and which events destroyed certain prime
factors that appeared in the
factorization of that particular integer
um okay anyway so one question you might
have at this point is you know
we have this global multi-system
framework that accommodates all these
different system types how does it
manage to be so general how you know how
can the same functions kind of work for
these
for such radically different sets of
systems well the key is because the
the for all of these different systems
the actual internal uh sort of
the the the guts of multi-way system are
the same in all cases
because all of these different systems
ultimately compile down
to one single canonical specification
which is a specification in terms of a
particular
association which consists of a state
what's called a state evolution function
a state equivalence function
a state event function
a event decomposition function
an event application function
a system type which isn't strictly
needed but which we use just for
bookkeeping purposes
and an event selection function which by
default is the identity
okay so then every single multi-way
system that i've shown you so far
internally is represented using using
this particular association
so what does this mean the reason i'm
writing this out is i want to kind of
show you how if you wanted to
you could go about in constructing your
very own sort of multi-way system format
from scratch just by programming in the
kind of low-level machine code that is
this association
so the way that it works is the state
evolution function is a pure function
that takes in a particular state and a
set of rules and
outputs all possible states that could
be obtained from that state given those
rules
so as an example let's take a string of
place list
if we did a hash string replace list
a goes to a a b goes to a b
sorry so then that would be a pure
function which if we then applied it to
a would give a a but if we applied it to
a a it would give aaa
if we applied it i don't know to a b a
i'm kind of making this up now okay so
that's that's giving us so when we
before right at the beginning when we
were running these uh when we were
looking at these all states lists
i forget where we were doing that or
maybe i deleted the code but
when we took when we took one of these
multi-way systems like if i take
i don't know uh this multi-way system oh
no let's take this multi-way system here
and we run an all states list all it's
doing is applying the state evolution
function
to each state in that list so if we take
all states list
like that so so and so it's just being
generated by pure application of the
state evolution function
so this is this would be the example of
the state evolution function for this
particular string substitution system
then the state equivalence function is
the function that takes it
again it's a pure function that takes in
a hash one and a hash two and it outputs
true if those states are equivalent so
in the case of strings or lists or
cellular automata
actually the state equivalence is
trivial we can just use state we can
just use same queue
to determine you know are these strings
equivalent should we merge them in this
in the all states graph
uh the the only the only real system
we've considered so far where there's a
non-trivial state equivalence function
is the wolfram model case
and so in that case our state
equivalence function is just uh
isomorphic hyper
isomorphic ordered hypograph q
and so that's how we that's how we
manage the the state merging in the
wolfram model case
okay so that's the state equivalence
function what's the state event function
so the state event function just as the
state
evolution function takes in a
specification of a state and a set of
rules
and outputs all possible states you can
obtain the state event function takes in
a specification of a state in the set of
rules and outputs all of the events that
could be applied
so actually if as long as you in reality
there's a small amount of redundancy
here because as it turns out
given the state event function and the
event application function it's always
possible for you to reconstruct the
state evolution function but
nevertheless
it's it's a useful optimization for
specifying the state evolution function
separately
because in many cases particularly in
the wolfram model case running the state
event function and then doing the event
application function is significantly
slower than just running the state
evolution function
okay so in the in our case if i do
something like string
get string event no wait what would it
be
get string state event function so just
to show you an example if
i take these the event the string event
function
here and i
do that and i apply this to our friendly
state there abva
uh where did i get the brackets from
there we go that's not good oh
this should be a list of states in
general okay so so then what that's
telling us is given this set of rules
and given this particular state
this is showing us all the possible
events that could get applied so that's
that's the purpose of the string
of the state event function for each of
our systems
then the event application function does
kind of the opposite
what it does is uh given a particular
event it works out i mean again in the
string case it's kind of trivial because
you can just take the output
you you basically do a string join of
the of the prefix
the the output and the suffix so if i
use string
event application function of that event
it will tell me that that this is a b a
a b b a
because if i just do a string join of
the prefix which is
null and the output which is aa and the
uh suffix which is bba i would get the
same thing so so
the event application function takes an
event and produces the output state that
would that would be achieved by applying
that event
system type is just a string it's a book
holder a bookkeeping string that's best
that
tells you the name of the system you're
considering like string or from model or
whatever
we use that for some internal rendering
code but but beyond that
it's kind of it's it's basically not not
really considered
and then event selection function is
something i'd like to discuss separately
but essentially what the event selection
function does is if you don't want to
apply all possible events you only want
to apply a particular subset of the
possible events
the event selection function is the
thing that takes in the specification of
all the list of all the possible events
you could apply
and kind of whittles it down to a
particular set of events to apply so
in in the default case event selection
function is set to be identity
uh but if you wanted to you could set it
to be i don't know first of hash or
something and then you basically get a
sequential substitution system
because you'd always be applying the
first event that could possibly be
applied
okay so given all of that let's try to
actually construct a multi-system
manually from scratch
by using okay we're going to use our uh
string replace list event state
evolution function uh state equivalence
function
is just same q uh if we ignore the state
event function let's just
set that to be identity in fact let's do
the simplest case let's not care about
any of the event related stuff let's
just care about the state-related stuff
and we'll call this a we'll call this a
string
system and event selection function is
going to be identity
and if we then plug that into multi-way
system
and we give it some initial condition so
what initial condition should i use i'll
use a b
a b a b and then we'll do that three
states graph
and it doesn't work why doesn't it work
i must have mistyped something
uh
[Music]
ah that should be a list and then it
doesn't work because
we didn't specify any event rendering or
state rendering functions but if i
oh yeah that's that's a useful thing to
know if if you're uh fed up of seeing
these nicely rendered
uh graphs thing you know when you call
states graph or evolution causal graph
or anything any of these other things
obviously all of the nodes automatically
get rendered using you know whatever
whatever the standard system type is but
you know in this case we didn't specify
what the system type was and we didn't
specify any of the rendering functions
so we didn't know how to render that
states graph but if you wanted to
for any of these systems you could you
can explicitly turn off the rendering
just by taking by appending the word
structure to the end of the property so
if you instead of calling evolution
causal graph
you can call evolution causal graph
structure and then it will just show you
the graph
without any fancy rendering and actually
often that's quite useful if you want to
run things quickly
because particularly in cases like
warfarm model or cellular automaton the
rendering is really quite slow
in comparison to the multi-evolution
okay so then okay calling states graph
structure
we for our manually coded multi-way
system we end up with this
and just to check that we did actually
do this correctly we can compare that
against the built-in string substitution
system framework so if we do
a goes to aa b goes to a b
for initial condition a b a b a b three
states graph structure
hopefully fingers crossed we get the
same thing yes
okay that looks pretty much the same
uh all right okay so then um
i already mentioned about sort of
possible updating orders a way that you
can select possible ways that you can
select possible updating orders
so if you're suppose you're not
interested in uh let me um is this a
good example yeah this is a reasonable
example if i do
a goes to a b goes to a b the same
example we treated above
and then we consider the case like this
so if i look at the multi-way causal
graph for that this is showing the
causal you know the multi-way causal
graph for all possible updating orders
but maybe you don't care about that
maybe you just care about the the you
know the causal graphs
for a particular updating order well
then what you can do
is rather than requesting causal graph
we can request causal graph instances
and that shows you essentially for if
for every possible path
if we look at the evolution causal graph
what causal graph instances is doing is
it's traversing every possible path
through the evolution causal graph and
it's looking at all of the causal edges
that you hit
and then well it's looking at all of the
events that you hit and therefore all of
the causal edges you kind of pick up
by peeling off all of these different
possible updating orders and then it's
just showing you a big list of all the
possible
single event history causal graphs and
uh you know in this
even for three evolution steps there are
quite a few if you want to limit the
number of ones you're shown you can just
use max items goes to like
five and it will only show you five
okay sorry so then if we
consider doing
uh if we take say the string
substitution system aba
a goes to b and we do i don't know
aabaa um so in addition to just having a
states graph so with a states graph if
you have
um this is probably a bad example
actually let me think let me see if i
can think of a better example to
illustrate this
um what we want is a string substitution
system that doesn't just grow we want
something that also shrinks
okay i'm going to try and invent one in
real time which may not work so well
so if i do an aba goes to
uh no that's kind of boring if i do that
is that going to do anything interesting
no is the answer okay forget it uh let's
just treat this case
so uh in in the ordinary states graph uh
because of the because of the presence
of the state equivalence function in
this in in the association
uh any any states that end up being
equivalent with respect to that state
evolution
with respect to the state equivalence
function will end up being merged in the
states graph but there might be cases in
which you want to kind of switch that
off in some way
so then there are a bunch of ways you
can do that one of them is to consider
uh this thing that we call the evolution
graph so the evolution graph
uh doesn't merge so what will happen is
the evolution graph will go through the
through the evolution of the system one
step at a time and it won't
merge uh it won't merge states that
appear on separate uh sort of
evolution steps so if you have if you
have an occurrence of say a aaa that
occurred at step one
and an aaa that occurred at step two if
you're requesting the state's graph
they'll get
merged but in the evolution graph they
won't because they're on different time
steps
but in the evolution graph as it's
normally constructed they will still get
merged if they
if there are multiple states that are
the same that appear on the same time
step
then they will be merged you can switch
that off by by requesting evolution
graph full
so or evolution graph okay right
evolution graph full what this is doing
what this is doing is it's showing
uh all possible events that could be
applied uh so
in the ordinary stage graph and in the
ordinary evolution graph uh sort of all
event all
equivalent event instances are merged so
if you have if you had a particular
state a
and another state b and there were sort
of two possible ways from getting
of getting from eight from state a to
state b uh in the in the default states
graph
that would just be shown as a single
line but if you wanted to see all the
possible ways of doing that
you can request the evolution graph full
so effectively this is not this is
refusing to merge equivalent events
there's an equivalent there's a way you
can do that in the states graph as well
which is by setting an option which is
called
include event instances it goes to true
that that kind of that gives you the
equivalent way of doing that just using
a
a states graph um if you wanted to not
just m
if you wanted to merge uh if you wanted
to turn off merging not just for events
but also for states
then you could request the evolution
graph on merged
and that would so now nothing is getting
merged at any time there's
there's two independent uh evolution
events uh that
not only are they shown as separate
edges but they also yield separate
states even if those states are actually
equivalent
um and if you wanted to in instead of
showing the these things as multi edges
these sort of event multiplicities as
multi edges
if you just wanted to kind of weight
each evolution edge by the number of
independent events
that sort of correspond to it then we
can request the evolution graph
graph weighted in which case now if we
switch on vertex labels
say vertex labels goes to vertex weight
then now you can see
this was an incredibly boring example um
can i think of a better example
uh because these all have weight one
that is so dull okay hang on wait let me
do we have any better ones maybe this
one will work better
if i do three evolution
graph weighted
vertex labels vertex weight see what we
get
no we also get a really boring thing
that is rubbish okay there are
definitely examples of this in the
documentation that i found where it
gives something non-trivial
uh if you want to see a demonstration of
how that works go look in the
documentation but i
uh i don't have the i don't have the
intelligence to construct an example of
that
uh off the bat i thought this one would
work but for some reason it didn't
anyway okay that's what happens so uh in
addition to the evolution graph stuff
uh what we could do so it's not just
evolution graphs that can end up being
that can have
non-trivial weights of vertices and
edges we can also consider oh
no i know what i did i did something
really stupid i it's not the it's not
the vertices that are labeled
edge labels goes to edge weight
there we go okay that's what i meant to
do so here you see so so this event had
multiplicity 2
so it should so in this case in the case
of the evolution graph full it showed up
as two separate
separate edges but in the evolution
graph weighted it shows us a single edge
with with weighting of one or with
weighting of two sorry uh yeah okay
that's what i wanted to show
the world makes sense again okay so now
uh if we consider instead of having uh
weighted evolution graphs
with weighted edges we can also consider
weighting the states graphs with
weighted states
so if we take something like a goes to a
a b goes to a b
a a b a b a a and then we do three in
states graph
okay so that's that's the states graph
that we see then what we could do is we
there are many different possible ways
we could weight to this state's graph so
one one immediate way we could do it
would be by saying uh include state
weights goes to true so what that's
going to do is it's going to say
so for each level for each layer in the
states graph uh
how many sort of what proportion of all
of the states that appear on that layer
is this particular states
so in other words if we didn't do any
merging what proportion
of the full unmerged states graph would
correspond to this particular state
so if we do that and we actually switch
on the vertex labels this time
then we could see okay so so in this
case here in the full
unmerged states graph there are
apparently three there are apparently
seven
uh seven different states that would
have appeared at level two here
of which three sevenths of them are the
states two seven some of them are this
state and two sevenths of them are that
state
and i'll show you in just a minute how
you could go about producing the full
fully unmerged states graph if if that's
what you wanted to do
but that's only one possible way that we
could have that we could have weighted
this thing
we could also have included state
pathways which would do what i think i
showed you just earlier
which is now now the the vertex weights
are demonstrating how many independent
evolution paths would have led to that
particular state
um okay so now uh
what if you want to if what if you're
given a multi-way system evolution and
you want to determine properties of its
causal and variants or you want to
determine things about its branch pair
resolution time
or things like that well uh multi-waste
is both multi-way system has
okay the multi-way system framework has
a bunch of built-in functions for doing
that
and i've also developed a bunch of
helper functions also in the function
repository that do that in a kind of
more specialized way
so let me begin by showing you some of
the helper functions if we take
uh actually okay let me not use that
system let me use a different system
so if i record if i call the function
branch pairs and i
use this system like a goes to a b a and
a a goes to b
and i call a a b a a two
i can see once it loads the resource
so i can see for this multi-way system
what were all of the branch pairs that
got that got produced in
within the course of its evolution um
but some of these are branch pairs that
will kind of resolve very quickly and
some of these are branch pairs that
might not resolve at all so if i wanted
to i could request branch pair
resolutions
and i could and what i should get back
is an association that tells me which of
these branch pairs are resolved
and which ones have not resolved after
two steps if we run it for another step
uh again we might take a little bit of
time because this is quite a complicated
multi-way system but again we can see
some of those branch pairs are resolved
but a lot of them have not so
i'm going to go ahead and guess that
this particular multiplayer system is
not called
variant because this this signature of
the resolution of the branch pair
resolutions
list being much smaller than the branch
uh unresolved list
is probably is usually indicative of a
non-complement system and hence
a non-causal invariant system so if i
now take this and i run
causal invariant q
it will complain at me for some reason
um
and it tells me it's false okay so this
is indeed not a non-causal variant
system
uh okay but i could also have done all
of those things within multi-way system
itself so if i
if instead of running this i called
multi-way system uh branch pairs
list i would have got the same result
and i could have called branch pair
resolutions list
and that would have failed branch pair
resolutions list
and it would give me the same result as
here and i could also call calls and
variant q
and it would give me the same result as
it would if i called the external
function so multi-way system has
has all kinds of built-in properties for
determining things like causal variance
branch pair resolution time it also has
ways of determining uh clintonics
completions
so this comes onto an interesting
question of sort of the relationship
between
the quantum mechanical aspects of global
multi-wave systems and the quantum
mechanical aspects of local multi-wave
systems
so as i'm sure max kind of mentioned in
his talk yesterday you know
one one interesting thing that can
happen in local multi-way systems is you
get interference between different
branches
that essentially occurs because you have
two hyper edges that are purely
branch-like separated
but that they can nevertheless be kind
of pulled into a single updating event
and so you get a new state but there's
somehow
an interference between those two
different branches in the global
multi-way system by default that doesn't
happen
because because the only the only events
that get applied are the ones that apply
to a particular state
and not sort of between pairs of states
but as i also mentioned in my quantum
mechanics lectures you can induce
interference kind of uh
in a post hoc way by performing a
kinetics completion
so the by analogy to the local
multi-weight case
if you consider the situation where you
have two states that are separated
sort of branch like separated at the
level of a single hyper edge uh
instead of just pulling both of those
hyperedges into a single event
and applying that uh the sort of the
global multi-way way of doing that of
imposing that interference
would be to say add in a completion rule
that allows you to hop from that
hyperedge to this other one
and back again and so uh and this will
give you
an again an interference effect between
those two branches which is uh you know
which again assuming the whole kind of
that our physics project
interpretation of how quantum mechanics
works is correct should give you the
same result as it would do if you had
kind of direct local multi-way uh
interference
so we can we can actually we should be
able to i mean i don't know how slow
this is going to be
but we should be able to demonstrate
that explicitly uh
just by using global multi-wave systems
so if we call clean appendix completion
it's going to take a moment to compute
that but what it will do
in fact i should have i should have not
done that i should have done this i
should say completion equals that
so that we actually have uh we have the
ability to store the completion rules
that get generated
so what this is going to do is it's
going to generate the kind of the
minimal completion list
that's needed to guarantee causal
invariance of the system so in effect
what's happening is
anytime you have hyperedges here that
are distinct from hyper edges here
it's adding in rules that allow you to
to sort of to jump from a hyper edge
here to a hyper edge here so it's it's
almost like it's imposing these branches
the branch-like separated events of the
local multi-way system as as a kind of
post-hoc step
by by performing a kinetics completion
so that's our list of completion rules
so if we collapse that down because it's
a bit ugly if we now go back and we
take our original multi-rate system and
we add
in let's say join that
with uh completion
and we give it a moment to run it will
take a little while because this is
quite a complicated system
and uh global multi-way systems are
reasonably slow
um but in a moment it should produce the
version of this in which there is
effective branchial interference uh
and which we can think of as being like
the the observer is performing
some measurement event or is performing
some measurement operation that is
causing
in their interpretation of the world
which is causal invariant uh it's it's
resulting in sort of
interferences between the multi-wave
branches that would not have been seen
if the observer hadn't chosen to make
that measurement
um this is taking longer than i would
have expected
uh i'm going to give it 30 seconds then
i'll kill off
oh no okay we're good okay now yes cool
now we have
uh so we see we end up with it with the
states graph that looks a little bit
different to this one
because now there are these new events
that allow you to effectively hop
from one branch of history to another by
by using the completion rules
and so so these are the and so these new
states that you can obtain
by the fact that you're able to now
effectively hop between these different
branches to hop between hyper edges that
lie on these different branches
those new states are the effective
interference states that exist between
those branches of history
and so uh our sort of conjecture is
those are the same
as the kind of branchially separated
events that you could apply in the
context of a local multi-wave system
and i believe hatham's project is
actually going to try and formulate that
conjecture and possibly
prove that conjecture in a slightly more
formal way than the way i've expressed
it here
okay so uh what i'm trying to show you
is that you know in addition to just
computing branch pairs you can also
compute things like mathematics
completions
um and again there are all kinds of
helper functions you can use in order to
do that so this is an example of a
kinesthenics completion you could apply
to a string substitution system
so if you want to test aspects of
quantum mechanics but you don't want to
bother to go through all the
computational effort of actually
simulating a full
multi-wave warfare model system you can
try out all of these completion steps
all the branch pass stuff
you can use that with any any other kind
of multi-way system be the string system
list system
cellular thomason system turing machine
whatever
okay but you'll have noticed that for
all of these branch pairs and these
cause and variance testings i've had to
specify explicitly kind of what what the
input
state was um but there's a notion of
kind of canonical branch pairs
so so given uh that there's a and so
canonical branch pairs are branch pairs
that exist kind of independent of the
initial conditions
they are they are the minimal set of
branch pairs that you need to sort of
consider
in order to evaluate properties like
global confluence and causal and
variance
so let me show you what i mean by that
so if i just give you uh if i say
canonical branch pairs
and i request let me do this
substitution system aa goes to aba
and aaa goes to b or something
and then i run that okay it's going to
show me this list so what does this list
mean well you can see i just specified a
string system i didn't actually specify
any initial condition
so these are this is the set of of
branch pairs that exist independent of
the initial conditions
and the way that canonical branch pairs
works that out is it looks at the
left-hand sides of all of the rules
and it computes the overlaps it computes
where could there exist ambiguities so
again to use the kind of formal
mathematical logic pollens
uh what it's doing is it's computing
critical pairs
in order to make that determination and
then it's showing you the minimal set of
critical pairs that exist for that for
that replacement system
so and that's something you can do even
without knowing the details of the
initial condition
and then if you wanted to you if we run
canonical branch pairs but with a time
step
it will even tell you which of those
canonical branch pairs resolve and which
don't resolve
after a certain amount of time and so
what that means is that in addition to
doing causal invariance testing which is
which is testing for causal invariants
for a particular initial condition
we can also do what we call total causal
and variance testing which is
determining is
is the particular rewrite system you
specified causal invariant
independent of which initial condition
you specified so in effect
what it's doing is a global confluence
check to determine given the set of
canonical branch pairs
do they all converge within a certain
period of time so in this case we can
see actually just by looking at the
canonical branch pairs this is not
globally confluent and hence can't be
cause the variant
and so we can we can see that explicitly
if we run total causal invariant q
and it tells us indeed that it's false
and again just like with
with ordinary uh just like with the
ordinary cosmic variance testing
functions we can run all of these
functions
these helper functions either as
separate function repository entries or
as properties within multi-way system
itself
so if i wanted to i could take i could
use multi-system and without giving it
an initial condition
i could just run i could say two comma
total causal invariant q and it would
tell me that this is not a causal
invariant system
now you may wonder you know why do we
have to specify a time step at all for
doing this causal and variance testing
that's simply a consequence of the fact
that
i mentioned multiple times i think in my
third lecture that because
the word problem on finite financially
presented monoids is undecidable
um we know that causal and variance
testing and you know
all the things that are involved in it
like global confluence testing those are
all undecidable problems in general so
if we just had a pure total causal
invariant q function
it would not be guaranteed to terminate
in general and that's kind of that's
that's not really a good thing
so to get around that i said uh let's
let's add in a time step that is
our time stamp that's that says we'll
evolve the system up to a particular
point and if it's still not causing the
variant by that
point we're going to assume it's not
causal and variant so that that's
effectively what that's doing
now if you want to if you want to do
more sort of in-depth causal variance
analysis and branch pair analysis
there are various other things you can
do you know you can include things like
uh predecessor states and successor
states let me show you how that works
so if we take a set of branch what did i
just do
okay we take a we take a set of branch
pairs like this
if we wanted to we could look at uh what
what were the predecessor states
so in other words what were the what
were the states where there existed a
rewrite ambiguity which yielded that
particular branch pair
which i can i can give just by setting
give predecessors to be true
so that will tell me that so uh so this
is telling me that in the multi-way
system aabaa
bifurcates to yield this particular
branch pair and this particular branch
pair and so on
um and then if i wanted to i could look
at the if i want to look at the the
resolutions
as i was doing before um then we could
ask in addition to
showing us we okay as before we could we
could tell it to to show us the the
particular predecessor states we could
also tell it
we could also ask branch pair
resolutions to tell us the resolvence
states
so for the branch pairs that resolved
what's what common state did they
resolve to
so we can say give resolvence goes to
true and now what it's going to tell us
is
this particular state aabea yielded this
branch pair
and then eventually after two evolution
steps or after a maximum of two
evolution steps
this branch pair reconverged on a common
state which is a b a
b a a b a uh and things like this and so
you can start to look at you know
what essentially what were the shapes of
the of the diamonds that existed
uh in the multi-way system that are
associated with branch pair resolutions
and things like that uh okay
so then uh and again just just to show
you the um sort of
the extensibility of this so if i do
canonical branch pairs
uh so so now if i give it instead of a
string system let's show it give it a
willful model system so this is going to
be a much more algorithmically
complicated activity
because what it has to do is effectively
you know determining string overlaps
uh determining doing critical pair
testing in strings is relatively
straightforward
doing uh determining hypograph overlaps
is a bit more complicated but
nevertheless
canonical branch pairs can do that
pretty quickly um if we wanted to
we could um i mentioned again in my
third lecture that one one often makes a
distinction between the existence of
of non-trivial critical pairs and the
existence of trivial critical pairs so a
trivial critical pair
is a situation where you have a single
element that can be rewritten in two
different ways to yield the same element
and so in within functions like
canonical branch pairs or canonical
branch pair resolutions
you can request it to also include the
the trivial critical pairs
by saying include self pairs goes to
true which i think in this case will
give it
um yeah so okay in this case there were
a few a few self pairs that kind of got
culled
in the default but which we can now dev
which we can now specify explicitly
okay so given information about things
like branch pairs and their resolutions
we have all the information we need to
be able to construct information about
the geometry of branchial space in other
words the the geometry of the space of
quantum states
so to do that let's take our let's take
one of our multi-way systems
and let's do again let's take the
strings case cause because it'll be
faster
let's do a goes to a to aba a goes to b
uh start with a b a a and let's do two
steps and let's request its branchial
graph
okay so we're going to get a branchial
graph what's this showing you well it's
showing you
so it's effectively showing you the
ancestry distance in the multi-evolution
graph
if we take the states graph of this
what this is telling you this is showing
you a particular branch like
hypersurface through the through the
multi-way evolution graph
and so it's telling you uh you know if a
pair of states are separated by a single
branchial edge
then they have a common ancestor
distance of one if they're separated by
two
uh branch ledges then they have a common
ancestor the distance of two
and so on um if we want so by default
uh branchial graph only shows you the
the the collection of states that are
bound in branch pairs that did yield
that were the consequence of ambiguous
updating events of course in general
there could be states that were achieved
by just following a single evolution
branch
in which case there's no ambiguity they
don't list they don't live in branch
pairs
and branch your graph won't show you
that by default although again just like
with all the other defaults
in multivariate system there is a way to
override it you can just say include
full branch your space
goes to true and uh that won't do
anything um
this is probably a bad example to try
uh oh let me try that no again a bad
example
can anyone think of a better example uh
okay no i actually i have an idea i
think i know a better example this would
be a better example a goes to a
a uh a goes to a b would be something
good and then
if we just started from a single state a
try that
no that didn't work either
ah i know what we can do we can cheat we
can do that okay yeah
that'll work all right that's going to
illustrate my point a bit better so if
we didn't include full branchial space
this would just show you this branchial
graph but because we've included this
kind of trivial updating event here
this doesn't produce any branch pairs
because the state is always the same
so by default those states are going to
be left out of the branchial graph where
we can include them by using include for
branchial space
um okay so let me now show you some
things about i mentioned before i was
going to go into a bit more detail about
the distinction between states graphs
and evolution graphs so let me now do
that
so uh if i do
let's try another multi-way system let's
again do a string substitution system
uh what should we use let's see let's
use the same one
no let's not use the same one let's use
this one let's use aa a goes to a a
b goes to a b and let's do aba
three states graph
i keep misplaying states graph this is
bad okay right so this is this is our
standard grid-like multi-system that's
used in all of the documentation
examples because it behaves really
nicely
um so if we now uh if we take this thing
and we look at its all states list you
can see that
you know by default it's merging merging
all of the possible states
uh but one thing that we could we might
want to do and okay and actually again
if we look at it's all events list
uh it's doing the same thing but suppose
now we wanted to say
don't merge states that appear on
separate uh time steps so in this
particular case it won't make any
difference
but uh if we also wanted to say don't
merge any states at all
the way we could do that is by saying
include state okay
let me just show you this and then we'll
explain how it works so if i say include
step number goes to true
include state id goes to true
so now what we get is a completely
unmerged states graph
and the reason it's completely unmerged
is because uh
by saying include step number goes to
true we're saying every state has its
associated step number so what that's
telling you
is that you if you have two equivalent
states but they exist on different uh
if they're existing at different time
steps they were generated at different
time steps
so they have different step numbers then
they don't get merged because same queue
will not return true in that case um
so so in other words what the evolution
graph is doing the reason why the
evolution graph differs from the states
graph is because the evolution graph
includes step numbers by default
but what we're also doing in addition to
including the step numbers is including
the state ids
so what the state id is is a u is
effectively a uu id for each each
individual state so now because the uid
is unique
uh none of the states can get merged
because none of them you know
for no pair of states is same queue
going to return true even if the
individual strings are true
are the same the uuids will be different
and so they won't get merged
so let me show you how that works
internally so if we say
if we just did include step number goes
to true and we didn't
we requested an all states list then now
you can see we have zero goes to aba one
goes to aaba so it's so
you so effectively each state is now
specified by uh by a rule
that has the step number on the left and
the state on the right uh if we
if we included if we just included the
state ids
then it wouldn't include a step number
but it would include so the step number
is going to be set to automatic but it
would include a uuid which is just this
string of numbers
and if we include both a step number and
a state id
sorry
then you can see uh both things are
incorporated and so if we
showed the events list uh the
the uh uuids and step numbers also
propagate down to the events so
essentially
how the events work is through something
like a kind of like a sort of hashing
system
where the what what the event is the the
id for the event is a list
containing the state id for the input
state and the state id of the output
state and so this means it's still
possible for your event application
function to determine
what the uh what the input state was and
the output state was including
the step number and the state id because
it can just take the first element of
the event id
or the second element of the event id uh
um i'm aware i'm i'm just about out of
time so i and there were a bunch of
other things i wanted to show you so
maybe maybe those will come up in
discussion or in questions
but just just before i i was going to
show you some stuff about how you can
construct your own rendering functions
and some other some other customizations
you can do
to incorporate your own kind of code
into multi-way system but uh just before
we wrap up let me show you kind of
a couple of different variants uh of of
this system so
so multi-base system that the regular
global multi-way system
applies both space light separated and
branch-like separated events
and and it demonstrates but so so both
separations are shown
so for instance in this case here in the
case of a goes to a b
goes to a b even though there are
actually no bro no there are no purely
branch-like separated states
or no purely branch like separated
events because every you know
every place where this could get applied
is either at an a or a b and there's no
overlap between a and b
um so in other words everything is
purely space-like there's no real
branching the only branching that
appears
is is the trivial space-like branching
um so
one thing you could ask is can we
construct a multi-way system which
doesn't show any of the space like
branching it only shows the branch-like
branching
and so the answer is yes and it's this
function i developed called generational
multi-way system
so if we run generational multi-way
system on this
you will see hopefully in a moment when
it wakes up and imports the
sorry okay there we go now it's working
right so generational multi-way system
for the same system you'll see doesn't
have any branching because what
generational multi-way system is doing
is it's taking the it's taking the input
and it's applying not just a single
event at each step but it's applying the
maximally consistent set of space like
separated updating events
so in the generational multi-way system
you know that all of the bifurcations
that exist
are bifurcations that exist purely
because of branch-like event separation
rather than a mixture of branch-like and
space-like event separation so in the
generational multi-let me
construct a generational multiplayer
system where there definitely is
branch-like separation so if i do a goes
to baa
if baa goes to abs for instance and i
say like that i do this okay so
there we have a generational multi-way
system uh where you can see
so each of these bifurcations is a
bifurcation that exists because there
was an ambiguity
in there was effectively an overlap
between the inputs for the events not
just because they happen to be spaced
like separated
if we wanted to we could see the all
states list for that or uh we could see
the all states list for this
or something like that so if you want to
if you want to reproduce behavior that's
that's more like
uh that's kind of if you want to
reproduce something that's showing you
the purely quantum mechanical behavior
of the system with none of the kind of
space like separated stuff
then generational multi-way system is
the function to do that
um there are also some functions that
stephen and i developed for doing kind
of
more uh for more pleasant rendering of
some of these substitution systems
and multi-way systems so we have this
function multi-way evolution plot
that's kind of uh if you want to
reproduce some of the pretty pictures
that stephen has in his
technical introduction many of them for
the case of uh of multi-way systems were
produced using multi-way evolution plot
which is a way of showing you if we do
evolution event rendering
goes to positional polygons
okay oh sorry then uh so this is an
example of a
of a multi-evolution plot for that so
this is a way of showing explicitly
where each event got applied
what the input to the event was what the
output for the mountain was and what the
overlaps are you can
so the the explicit overlaps are going
to be highlighted uh
with these kind of with these darker
gray regions where these two events
happen to overlap with each other
uh sort of which you can see
geometrically by looking at the
positional polygons that show where the
events got applied
so there are there are some more so in
addition to some some nice helper
functions which do cool algorithmic
things
there are also some nice helper
functions which do cool rendering things
uh again a complete list of these things
uh is shown on the wolfram physics
website under the tools guide page
which actually is currently a little bit
out of date because it doesn't include
several of the functions we've developed
more recently
but hopefully we'll be being updated in
the next few days um so i'm aware i
should i should probably stop talking
right about now
so let me stop sharing and if there are
any quick questions before the session
ends i'm happy to take them now